Santa has had a hard ass year or so I've  heard you know what Santa loves more  than just like basic [ __ ] cookies ice  cream cookie sandwiches and I've got a  lot of presents left to wrap so let me  show you my hack  step one buy some cookies and if you  know you know step two  buy some vanilla ice cream and here's my  little time saving hack  slice the ice cream  right out of the pint  take it right out okay so my ice cream  to cookie ratio is a little off but  isn't everyone actually here for the ice  cream let's move on to the next step  crushed candy canes  give it a good roll lots of festive  flavor going on sanitrated in a slate  for a flying saucer it is 2023. he  deserves an upgrade  cold